[Music]
welcome people watching on YouTube to
another speedrun game uh we're going to
do 10 plus zero just because I'm
recording this at at 5:00 a.m. and I
just had a really long stream so we're
going to do a bit of a shorter game but
I'm going to try my best not to
compromise on quality obviously I I
never do and we might get another GLE
system we might get another G system we
will get another G system let's go
G3 um so we had uh this system I debuted
this system a couple of speedrun games
ago with great success and in that first
game we also faced uh Bishop C5 which is
the most common response online so we
continue with our development Bishop G2
D6 and we secure the E4 Pawn with D3 so
these are all standard moves so far
we're following that other game and
we're going to make the improve movement
uh that we analyzed in that other
speedrun game so there is a a very
important move that top GMS play with
black in this type of position which is
A6 or A5 does can anybody tell me why
what happens if black doesn't play A5
what is the way to quote unquote punish
black positionally the real Ure through
Franklin got it yeah it's Knight A4 and
this is the computer suggestion we
didn't play this move in the last game
but the point is that it gives white the
bishop pair and once you eliminate the
bishop from B6 it becomes a lot easier
for us uh to carry out the D3 D4 Pawn
break now we don't even have to rush
with Knight takes B6 that Bishop isn't
really going anywhere so we can proceed
with our development for the time being
we can castle and we can play H3 so we
can play all the standard improving
moves and then when the moment is right
uh and when the moment is ripe depending
on how you want to say it we can play
Knight takes B6 so how do we improve our
position what does it mean to improve
our position here well it's always a
good idea to play H3 uh in the GLE
system to restrict the active
development of this bishop now that
we've made most of the quote unquote
nice moves I think it's time for us to
grab the
bishop and now we need to address the
pressure on the A2 Pawn now you might
say well isn't Rook takes A2 not a
threat because white can take and play
B3 yes but that's a bit of a headache
how do we eliminate this headache while
also guaranteeing a good Square for this
bishop and again I'm directly bwing
ideas from our previous analysis so I
remember a very similar position and the
engine in this very similar position
likes to play B3 yeah the engine likes
to play B3 fiano the bishop and
eventually sooner rather than later
we're going to push D4 and when we push
D4 the position opens up and when it
opens up we exploit the fact that we
have the bishop air and we have the more
compact uh development the more active
development okay so Knight H7 clearly
our opponent is preparing F5
and that affords us a sense of urgency
that tells me that okay if I don't play
D4 now Black's likely going to play F5
and develop counterplay on the king side
um so even without playing Bishop B2 my
inclination here is to immediately push
D4 I think the time has come because
we're obviously threatening a fork we're
threatening D5 and we're trying to force
black to give away the E5 Pawn after
which we will assert a much larger share
of the Center so we're threatening
D5 there's that trade we play Knight
takes D4 we could even consider the move
Bishop to B2 here but I didn't like the
response Knight G5 I'll talk I'll talk
about that after the game so black could
force the queen trade here if he so
desires who can okay never mind we'll
talk about that after the game black
could have forced the queen trade here
but I think that white is better even in
the end game Bishop D7 is kind of a
passive move um we should simply
continue our development I don't see a
reason for us to do anything
extraordinary we haven't completed our
development there's Bishop B2 and now we
have completed our minor piece
development our Bishops are perfectly
located crisscrossing the board along
the long diagonals and we have a much
larger share of the center due to the E4
Pawn so our opponent stubbornly insists
on playing F5 but because we have
already completed our development this
is a much less scary move and it's a
much less scary move because it makes a
huge concession it allows us to open up
the diagonal for our light squirt Bishop
which I am absolutely happily going to
do now let's try to maximize our
initiative so what are the options
available to us well of course we could
chop off the other bishop and we can get
two Bishops against two knights which in
a wide openen position definitely favors
the side of the Bishops now some of you
might be attracted to the possibility of
winning a pawn right you can take twice
on C6 okay that's not a bad option but
it does leave black with a relatively
active bishop and I also want to to
avoid whenever possible moving the
bishop out of its fien kto Square
because it does loosen up the king a
little bit so we're going to play this
very very positionally uh there's also a
check on D5 but I don't really see what
that check accomplishes we are going to
take the bishop and we are going to play
the long game of having our two
superactive Bishops I think a lot of
people when they think about a position
like this they want to play these Tempo
moves you you're probably thinking right
now let's go Queen G4 let's go Bishop B4
but it's very important to be able to
play these positions
more gradually more slowly all of these
are one move threats that are quite easy
to Parry so Queen G4 black can play
Queen G5 Bishop B4 black drops The Rook
back to f8 and what have we accomplished
by centralizing the bishop we're
actually walking into potentially the
move Knight to G5 and that's kind of the
point here we need to play these slower
improving moves that might be a a lot
less attractive to you but I think they
produce more of an effect on the
opponent so how do we do that what kinds
of moves come to mind yeah the move
Queen D3 is a p purposeful one move
threat because if black defends The Rook
then we can skewer The Rook to the
Knight with uh Bishop to E4 so I really
really like starting with Queen to D3 it
hits the Rook but the what you should
understand is that the point of this
move is not that it creates a threat the
point of this move is that it connects
the Rooks and it centralizes the queen
we would likely play this move even if
the Rook was on f8 and of course black
blunders black blunders material who can
tell me how we win material in this
position Bishop B4 wins material that's
it it's a skewer and the GLE system will
prevail
again if we win this game quickly I will
definitely get a second speedrun game in
and then I'll put both of them in the in
the YouTube video which is how we used
to do it it's the power of the bishop
pair if the Rook moves for newer players
we can take the Knight because we are
attacking that Knight twice and it's
only defended once by the King this is
what's called a skewer skewers generally
happen along a diagonal or along a file
black loses what does black lose well
what how does black minimize his losses
well here's the sad thing yeah Rook af8
of course seems to minimize Black's
losses but it's very very important big
piece of advice when you're about to win
material right don't grab that material
without thinking take a moment and ask
yourself the question am I sure that I'm
maximizing my material gain maybe there
is a way to win even more material now
if you ask yourself that question you
should immediately spot a move that's a
lot better than Bishop takes F5
excellent you guys are all finding it
and it's the move G4 G4 wins the game on
the spot it wins a piece whereas Bishop
takes F5 only wins an exchange and black
can claim to have some compensation in
the form of the weakened King the fact
that we've given away our fenet of
course white is winning after Bishop
takes F5 but G4 ends the game G4 ends
the game ible chess Rook F3 we just take
it Rook F3 is not a move here resigning
is is definitely the preeminent option I
think for black because we won't stop
there we'll we're going to pick up this
Knight with check but it's not like the
attack stops at that Knight B4 what do
we do against Knight B4 who can tell me
what's an accurate response to the move
Knight to B4 which is not unlikely to be
played the best move I think is Queen to
C4 check black covers with D5 and who
can tell me in that position after
Knight B4 Queen C4 check D5 what do we
do there what do we do there we take the
Knight with a bishop and we hit the
Queen We simultaneously hit the queen if
black takes the bishop with the Rook
then the Knight on B4 is going to be
hanging that's it the game is over so
this was a very quick blunder by our
opponent who was playing too quickly but
the the the seeds of defeat were sown
earlier I think the seeds of Victory
were swn when we played Knight A4
because the bishop here in this in this
particular position the plan of carrying
out D4 is extremely extremely effective
practically it's a hard plan to meet and
the point I made in our first g game
that I think you can see now is that
people really struggle against this
opening people don't know where to put
their pieces and we could see that here
very very clearly okay let's finish this
off in style now of course the biggest
concern for us is that this bishop on H7
is very vulnerable and it's not a very
efficient use of our resources for the
Queen to be tied down to its protection
so it makes sense for us to pull this
bishop away and put it on a safe Square
there are two safe squares that I'm kind
of eyeing but there is only one square
with Tempo and the tempo square is
Bishop F5 Tempo square is Bishop F5
after the game I will talk about why the
move Queen G6 is wrong I know it was
tempting to some people now what is the
strategy for winning this position most
efficiently well we should keep in mind
that a queen trade is probably going to
end it very very quickly so we we will
not turn down a queen trade in general
we need to bring the rest of our pieces
into the game so your instinct should be
identify the piece that's not playing
bring it into the game it's not rocket
science Rook A1 of course you should
also make sure that you are identifying
the threats as they appear now here we
can use tactics to win the game here we
can use tactics to win the game who can
tell me what black is threatening who
can tell me what black is threatening
how do you determine the threat well you
should see that Queen G pins the G4 Pawn
well what is the G4 Pawn doing it's
protecting the bishop black is
threatening to take the bishop but you
should also notice that this puts the
queen and the Rook on the same diagonal
so the the Russian school boy move would
be Queen G3 this is the move that I
would recommend to a newer player if you
want to win the game tactically and you
want to win the game with a flourish you
can also play the move Bishop C1 you can
also play the move Bishop C1 pinning The
Rook to the
queen and likely this will lead to
complete liquidation and victory but
what happens if black plays Rook 8 takes
F5 what happens here and we have two
ways to win we can interchange the move
order but there is a there's a flashier
way to win what should we do what should
we do not Queen takes F5 nope nope by
far not the best move folks the first
win is to play Rook e a check but nobody
has named the second win what's the
second way to win yeah rookie eight is
one way but what else can we do what
else can we do I'm not playing the move
until someone names it in the
chat Bishop takes F4 and if Rook takes
F4 Rook E8 is Checkmate this is the
detail that a lot of you guys missed so
the good lesson here is that just
because there is a Pawn on H6 doesn't
mean that you shut off the idea of back
rank M back rank m is still very much
possible if you're controlling the Luft
Square for the king now of course we
play Queen takes F5 and that's it we
force the queen trade notice that Rook r
eight check would have been a lot worse
because of Rook f8 okay was a simple
game Let's quickly go through it and we
can get another one in and put it in the
same
video so I think you were able to see in
this game why if black plays this line
black has to push the a pawn here uh or
on the next move so for instance d63 the
best move for black is to play A5 and
the point of A5 is to take the sting out
of the move Knight A4 to preserve
Black's Bishops and I did some analysis
in this line uh in the in the previous
game I did some analysis in the previous
game in the previous g game that I'll
link in the description let me see if I
can copy this one sec to chess space
let's take a quick look at the course of
the game so our opponent did not play a
A5 and most people that you face are
also not going to play A5 we decided to
play Knight A4 this time an improvement
over the previous game okay so Bishop B6
castles castles h 3 improving our
position preventing Bishop G4 Bishop B6
developing and we decided that this was
a good opportunity for us to take on B6
and prepare to expand in the center with
uh Bishop B2 and D4 now I think the only
way for black to maintain approximate
equality would have been to beat us to
the punch what what do you think black
should do here what do you think black
should do here what's the best
move it's D5 black has to play D5
basically black has to stake his claim
it's like the California Gold Rush you
have to arrive first I still like
White's position after D5 I still think
that white is a little bit better here
and so does the engine um white can play
Bishop B2 and if black plays D we just
play D takes C4 notice that after Queen
takes D1 first of all we take with the F
Rook to keep the a pawn protected but
the tactics work out for why Knight
takes E4 we simply play Knight takes E5
Knight E5 Bishop E5 and black is in
quite a bit of trouble in fact black
will lose a pawn because this is a
double attack on the Knight and the C7
Pawn so it's not like D5 solves all of
Black's problems after D5 Bishop B2 the
best move is Queen to D6 and I think
White's position is very pleasant you
can play this weird move A4 preparing
Bishop A3 to skewer the queen and the
Rook the engine gives Rook f8 Rook E1
and white is a very very convenient
position D de I like white you know
Bishop pair you've got some pressure on
E5 it's about point two but still I
think this would have offered black the
best practical chances after Knight H7
D4 I think black's position is already
very bad and I think it gets worse after
black plays Bishop D7 this is one
inaccuracy and I would go so far as to
call F5 nearly the decisive mistake yeah
and the engine
agrees black has I think only one
feasible way to proceed here which is to
try to get as many pieces off the board
as possible how does black do that well
you might think it's Queen F6 but it's
not because here we can play Bishop B2
and you have no way to force the queen
trade you should take on D4 first and
then go Queen F6 how do you find
something like this well it's very
important to realize that White's Rooks
are not yet connected so you should ask
yourself from Black's perspective how
can I exploit the fact that the Rooks
are not connected yet well you can
exploit it very directly by targeting
The Rook in the corner in general I
should point out the tactics that
exploit like trapped Rooks or undefended
Rooks in the early middle game can be
very hard to find
that sounds like an obscure point but
let me give you an example of one of
those sudden tactics that stems out of
nowhere which targets a rook an an
uncoordinated rook in the corner here's
a game that I remembered for many years
so this is a game from when I was
1600 and it's a completely normal
run-ofthe-mill position from an alipin
and I decided that I'm gonna play B6 and
I'm gonna fetto my bishop and I won the
game I won the game pretty uneventfully
I won a bunch of his pawns he was rated
a thousand okay after the game I got
yelled at by my coach why what did we
both Miss in this position what would
have happened here somehow Bishop F3
you're exactly right you want to get the
bishop to F3 Knight E5 exactly why
Knight E5 why not Knight D2 because here
the queen has the D7 square and black is
okay so you put the Knight on E5 and you
win the game on the spot black has no
way to stop Bishop F3 winning the rook
in the corner none Bishop B7 Bishop F3
that's it you also lose the bishop here
nothing that black can do so again
anytime your Rooks are uncoordinated you
should be aware of where your Rooks are
positioned and you should be aware of
these types of traps okay all right so
what's the evaluation of this end game
well white is better but of course black
can defend I would say it's about4 or5
very unpleasant for black we have a
great Center but the game will drag on
for quite a long time um and this I
think was the most resilient defensive
continuation for black if F4 black
should probably play Knight C5 and try
to get this bishop around to Target the
E4 Pawn um but instead our opponent let
us complete the development and then
created a decisive weakening of the
king this was the most instructive
moment of the game a lot of people here
would take on C6 twice and I think this
is actually a serious mistake not a
serious mistake but it complicates the
procedure tremendously after something
like Bishop takes H3 okay and here you
can see why it can be so dangerous to
leave the parking spot on G2 because if
you take the Rook on A8 black actually
wins the game with Queen takes A8 and
suddenly you have no way to defend these
light squares um so we decided instead
to go for the bishop pair and that was
much much easier Queen D3 obviously
there was no reason for our opponent to
lose the game like this black should
have dropped the Rook back to f8 and
here the engine proposes A really lovely
move really lovely move wouldn't you
love to dislodge this knight from C6 if
you could dislodge this Knight then the
bishop really comes alive can you find a
tactical way to make that happen can you
find a tacal way to make that
happen Bingo B4 now guess why this
tactic exists it's because black played
F5 so F5 is such a bad move not only
because it gives away the bishop but
because it also seriously weakens the
king B4 and black is in huge trouble
King h8 you can play B5 you
excommunicate the Knight and then you
occupy the E file and you should it
should be clear to you the black's
position is horrendous The Rook is
coming in the queen is coming in black
is paralyzed the Knight has no squares
it's completely lost okay and if you're
watching this on YouTube you should
pause the video and you should really it
should soak in the fact that this
position is losing because material is
equal but it should make sense to you
why black is in trouble in the in the
short run
okay um so Queen D7 Bishop E4 and the
game is over last point I wanted to make
is that Queen G6 would be a very poor
move because it doesn't actually really
threaten anything and it actually closes
down the bishop so black would have had
Knight E5 and white loses the majority
of their advantage because now you have
to eliminate your dark squired bishop
and you're going to have a very very
hard time getting your queen and Bishop
out of there in fact it's impossible
because if you now try to evacuate black
has this move Rook D4 and you have to go
right back where you came from and then
black could push you away again and win
back the bishop so don't overdo it right
don't play a move like Queen G6 on
instinct when you whenever you win
material you have to reassess the
situation you have to ask yourself what
are the top priorities how do I
consolidate and here the top priorities
are to evacuate the bishop to a safe
Square which we did and then activate
the Rook which we did and that gave us
this rookie eight idea which won the
game okay easy simple game the GLE
system strikes again let's play another
10-minute game I'll put this second game
up on YouTube as well hopefully we get
us a little bit more meat on the bone
but I hope you enjoy that one but
hopefully I'm converting some people to
the GLE system it's very easy to play it
it really develops your positional
understanding and it'll give you some of
these quick wins if you if you
understand the the correct
ideas there we go defend trat we're
playing an NM oh we're playing Brian
Weiss big shout out to Brian Weiss he uh
is a young player I know Brian he uh
participated in a couple of Chess camps
that I taught at in Atlanta I think so
Brian was in my home room group he's a
very talented young player from New York
I think big big shout out welcome to
Brian let's get started we have the
white pieces again so this could even be
a themed I think Brian plays the fidor
this could even be a themed speed run on
on the GLE system but I'm if I remember
correctly Brian might play some side
yeah he plays the fidor so we're facing
the
filor and in the spirit of playing
dangerous Sidelines I want to play
something against the filor that's not
necessarily the main line but that
offers a pretty decent you know
alternative option that you don't really
need to memorize now what's the main
move well the main move is D4 but a good
way to avoid the main lines is to
develop your Bishop to C4 Gary Kasparov
actually liked this move you start with
Bishop C4 okay Knight F6 huh so Knight
G5 here I don't remember but I don't
think you're supposed to play Knight G5
we're going to make the very modest move
D3 and we're going to transition the
game into a line of the Italian where
black has already committed essentially
to developing this bishop to E7 or to G7
right the difference between this
position and the main Italian is that if
you play the Italian with Bishop C4
you're giving black the additional
option of Bishop C5 which is of course
the main line so it's a small concession
but it's a meaningful concession this is
like a passive version of an Italian for
black if that makes sense so now we
complete continue our development we
continue our development we can do that
in a variety of ways we can put the pawn
on C3 or we can put the Knight on C3 I
like doing things straightforwardly
let's just play Knight C3 and continue
our development for now easy line you
don't have to remember any Theory you
just kind of develop your pieces and you
have a fairly Pleasant position black
can equalize of course with accurate
play but you know it's it's openings
aren't all about just trying to win out
of the gates a good idea is to play H3
as we do in the GLE system to prevent
the Bishop from coming out to G4 because
when we Castle when we castle and black
plays Bishop G4 it's a lot riskier for
us to play H3 and G4 if black had gone
Bishop G4 here then we would have of
course gone H3 and G4 and we would have
kept the king in the center or even gone
Queen side so H3 is an important
precursor to short castles yeah so black
has two main ways to play this position
one is to play Knight C6 and and get the
sort of italianesque situation
the other is to say well listen I'm
actually going to extract the maximum
from the position and I'm going to put a
Pawn on C6 and push D5 and that plan
looks very attractive and very appealing
but it's actually very very risky and if
black plays this I think I'll be able to
demonstrate that I've lost a lot of
games with black in in these types of
lines where I go C6 and D5 and then the
center comes under immediate Fire by all
of our minor pieces do we play A4 in
these structures or A3 uh it doesn't
doesn't matter particularly A4 has been
more fashionable lately just to grab a
little bit more space so I've seen top
GMS play A4 but I wouldn't even play A4
yet it's not well actually it might be
necessary but B5 is not a particularly
dangerous threat we could play A4 here
to prevent B5 but after A4 black plays
D5 we drop our Bishop back black can
play D takes C4 we play D takes C4 and
we get into an end game that end game I
think is about
so if possible I'd like to save a Tempo
on I'd like to save a Tempo on A3 I'd
like to Castle because if black plays D5
now we play Bishop B3 and the big
difference after D5 Bishop B3 is that if
black plays D takes C4 and we play D
takes C4 if black takes Our Queen we can
take back with the Rook okay and that's
huge that Rook on D1 will give us an
advantage in the end game whereas if we
had wasted a move on A4 and we had gone
down the same line my logic is that we
would have to take on D1 with the King
and then we'd have to waste another move
getting the king out of the D file and
those two extra Tempe I think would give
black enough time to complete his
development let's get our thing out of
the center this is 10 plus Zer by the
way so keeping an eye on the clock I
think Brian is probably deciding now
between D5 and B5 the best move I think
is B5 I don't think D5 is a good move
actually King h8 okay so kind of a
prophylactic move now what we want to
avoid here is Bishop B3 never play
Bishop B3 in these types of positions
because that blunders a piece to D5 and
D4 classic mistake Knight G5 is another
one of those paper tiger moves black
just goes Queen E8 I don't like Knight
G5 so we have a couple of ways to play
of course remember you can play D4 you
are allowed to play D4 at some point but
I want to save this move for a rainy day
let's begin by preventing B5 now that
we've castled I think we have the the
time uh to push A4 and to restrict the
the movement of the B
Pawn so let's go
A4 okay Knight G8 so Brian is very
clearly preparing F5 which is a very
Advanced plan but the move Knight G8
also undevelop the Knight so what do I
see when I look at this move well
Black's pieces are now essentially all
in the back rank what that tells me the
data that that gives me is well this
might be a good time to open the center
because the textbooks say that the way
you punish passive play is by opening
the center so as a lot of you guys are
already indicating D4 I think it's the
perfect opportunity for D4 unless I'm
missing something tactical which is
entirely possible this is going to be
real oh F5 I see what our opponent wants
very devious very devious by Brian okay
now I need to do some calculation here
yeah I missed I missed the detail here
if D takes E5 he's got F takes E4 takes
takes takes takes takes and we get that
crazy position I have no idea how to
evaluate it rookie one feels like it
should be good for white but it is risky
H4 R E4
H5 very tricky idea by Brian maybe we
should play Bishop takes G8 King takes
G8
D ah maybe aha what if we play Bishop
takes
G8 okay what if we play Bishop takes G8
first now does everybody understand what
the issue is after d Fe if we play
Knight takes C4 we run into the fork we
run into D5 Fork so let's start by
eliminating the Knight the point of this
move is not to trade the bishop for the
Knight it's to get rid of the bishop so
that when the king takes and I assume
Brian's going to take with a king we can
play D takes E5 F takes C4 and then hold
on to the extra Pawn with Knight takes
C4 and there we will be up a pawn now we
are giving away the bishop pair so
that's a little bit of compensation for
Brian but I feel like he's so poorly
developed that we will have time to
maybe even later get the bishop out to
G5 but that you know we'll cross that
bridge and we get there okay de now
there is of course this crazy line where
we both take each other's pieces I
didn't like that and I'll talk about
that after the game so the critical
moment was on move 10 okay D5 hitting
our Knight well I think we should move
it back probably to G3 why to G3 well
there two reasons the first is that I
want to get get the king a little bit
more safety a little bit more security
the second reason is later on I'm
thinking already about Knight sallyes
like Knight H5 you know the Knight on G3
if if you play the ru Lopez or you play
the Italian you should understand the
value of a knight on G3 it's got a lot
of potential energy this Knight on G3 um
Bishop takes H3 is not a move because
the Knight is defended by the queen but
this is a tactic that you should always
pay attention to whenever the f file is
open like this you should be very much
aware of Bishop takes H3 I'll show you a
great example of that after the game in
the Lopez black is worse clearly it's
clear to me that Brian missed Bishop
takes G8 and he's got insufficient
compensation for the pawn yeah so well
Queen D4 I wouldn't play anyway because
why are we centralizing the queen and
not our minor pieces okay so what are
our next moves likely to be well we're
going to complete our development I
assume it really depends on what black
does it depends on how Brian chooses to
position his pie because if he plays
Bishop E6 then what move becomes a lot
more tempting who can tell me if black
plays Bishop E6 what move is immediately
stems naturally from the position yeah
it's Knight D4 of course centralizing
and hitting the bishop but Knight D4 in
and of itself is probably not desirable
because that walks right into C5 so a
lot depends on what Brian does here he's
down to 3 minutes 50 seconds there's no
increment here we're only on move
13 Bishop C5 okay so he's setting up
some sort of threats along this diagonal
we could play Bishop E3 here actually
and trade off the Bishops but that would
come at the cost of compromising our
Pawn structure um so that would be one
way to play we could make a neutral move
like C3 to prepare B4 probably Brian
will play A5 there in response what I
don't like let me tell you what I don't
like I don't like Bishop G5 because that
walks into Queen to B6 and then black
sets up the battery and black hits B2 I
feel like that Bishop on G5 is is really
awkward like a middle schooler at a
dance it's like staring into nothingness
you know what you know what I think that
the best move here is actually and I
know this will come as a shock to people
but to play Bishop B3 yeah we could play
Queen E2 and Bishop E3 also but I like
Bishop E3
immediately takes takes now yes I
understand that we damage our Pawn
structure considerably but there is also
a perk of having these doubled Pawns the
pawn on E5 is very well protected for
the time being the pawn on E3 could
later advance to E4 and attack put
pressure on the D5 Pawn so I actually
don't think that these doubled pawns are
as bad as they look I also had to
account for the move Queen B6 which runs
into Queen to D4 important line and I'm
leaving black with two minor pieces both
of which are undeveloped and both of
which are stumbling over each other
Knight D7 okay so now E4
is very tempting but that does run into
the check on B6 but already at that
point I think we can play King H2 so I
like the look of E4 here I'm just
checking for tactics E4 E4 E4 E4 to me
E4 is begging to be played I think to
newer players maybe this move is a
little bit scarier to make um especially
if you notice that Queen B6 check will
Fork the king in the B2 Pawn but at this
point the B2 Pawn is immaterial because
I'm already thinking about checkm black
in the center so quick line Queen B6
check we move our King if black takes on
B2 there then we can play e takes D5 if
black plays Pawn takes pawn and then
plays Queen B6 check and then plays
Queen takes B2 can anybody tell me okay
well never mind we're actually going to
get this line we're actually going to
get this line King H2 King H1 probably
doesn't matter let me think probably
doesn't matter but maybe King H1 is
better you know why I like King H1 more
because the drawback is that the Knight
is unprotected but the benefit is that
later on I'm envisioning a scenario
where the queen could come back to E5
and if the king were on H2 that Queen on
E5 would pin the Knight on G3 now the
Knight is always going to be free to
move I understand that H2 looks better
H1 looks a little bit more unnatural but
in the event that the black queen
appears in the center I want our Knight
to be unpinned and I don't want there to
be a check on E5 okay so now now we have
some sort of weird tactics but I don't
see the need for that let's play Knight
takes C4 it it really shouldn't matter
King on H1 King on H2 I think it's
nonessential here and if Brian plays
Queen takes B2 it's time for us to
calculate then the game transitions into
pure calculation we will try to go after
his King we will try to use the E Pawn
of course E6 becomes
possible but I'm also worried about his
clock I don't really I really don't want
to win on time that might be the the
conclusion what do we do now well
there's a couple of candidate moves we
can play Queen to D6 and we can drive
Our Queen up into the center hitting the
rook and just stabilizing the situation
we can push E6 and E6 has to be
calculated because it's a Concrete move
E6 Knight F6 E7 Rook E8 I'm trying to
calculate that line B1 Queen A3 I think
it works I think it works I calculated
some really pretty lines let's go let's
let go E6 here we go if my calculation
are correct is correct we
win because of overwhelming threats E7
now we push the pawn again and here
after Rook E8 you have to avoid a lot of
very tempting options and I think I
found a very accurate move so what I
understood is that the Rook on F1 needs
to be participating in the action if you
can if you can orchestrate direct attack
on the on the F6 Knight then you'll be
threat Knight takes F6 check so a move
that kind of stems naturally from that
observation is this move Knight F to G5
and this is the move that I think wins
us the game because it creates a
completely insurmountable number of
threats now what was I actually thinking
about I was worried about Knight takes
C4 here and after Knight takes C4 we
have a beautiful mate we have a
beautiful mate mating sequence does
anybody see it what happens if Knight
takes E4 in fact there's probably
multiple winds but there's one very
clean mate very good Rook f8 Rook takes
f8 we take and make a queen king takes
f8 and queen d8 was made okay so this is
complete desperation obviously which
doesn't mean that we shouldn't take this
move seriously I think that the easiest
is just to take the bishop it's actually
a very ingenious defense um takes takes
Queen takes F takes Queen check King
moves I'm trying to see if there's a
cleaner win than just taking the bishop
because that will require some technique
we can probably
also no probably not I think we have to
uh yeah we simply take the bishop it's
not glamorous you know but oh Queen D3
what about Queen D3 setting up threats
against H7 Queen D3 Rook takes
E7 Queen C4 I'm trying to find the force
win here and I'm not quite finding it
Queen D6 may be possible Also let's
start with Queen D3 let's start with
Queen D3 and after after Rook takes E7
we're just going to take the bishop and
we're going to win the game with an
extra piece that's it no no frills just
you know maybe there is a force to win
maybe the engine will indicate something
Knight takes E4 but that loses on the
spot oh my gosh we have a we have a mate
we have a smothered mate check we have
smothered mate look at this now it's not
the only mate there but it is a
smothered mate and he resigns beautiful
Knight F7 Knight H6 que G8 Knight F7
that's your introduction to the bishop
C4
filor yeah that was a nice game uh good
game Brian thank you for playing so I
first learned about the move Bishop C4
uh from Gary Kasparov who played it uh
early in his chess
career and I'm not claiming that this is
a serious way to fight for the advantage
I think it just gives you a a fresh and
easy position to play that I do think is
more pleasant for white so Knight F6
um note that Knight G5 is bad here
because of the classic response D5 e
takes D5 and simply H6 pushing away the
Knight um in contrast to the fried liver
there is no Knight on C6 so the moveie E
takes D5 doesn't come with Tempo that's
why H6 is really annoying um so don't go
Knight G5 D3 is the is the way to play
Bishop E7 Knight C3 Castle's cast Castle
H3 we're still following you know a
relatively popular line there's hundreds
of games in the database josam just
played this couple months ago and C6
best move according to the engine and
best most popular bortnik had this with
black
castles and I see 90 games with Knight
bd7 I see 80 games with B5 the move our
opponent played King h8 one game in the
database Lopez against Lopez from 2001
so King h8 is a relatively new move it's
an interesting idea but ultimately I
don't think that this is the right way
to play um this is somewhere in between
Theory and not Theory it's like a
relatively non- theoretical line but you
know there are games um so let's
consider B5 for a sec first of all let's
consider D5 D5 we play Bishop to B3 and
ab bortnik played Queen D6 which is a
very clear sign that things are going
wrong and here white gets an amazing
position by playing e takes D5 C takes
D5 Rook E1 Knight C6 who can tell me a
very pretty tactic that essentially wins
the game pause the video if you're
watching on YouTube White to play and
win white to play
Win Knight takes E5 and Bishop F4 very
good and and Bishop F4 um and the game
is over I mean you just you don't even
have to play D4 immediately you can
actually you can play D4 but everything
collapses it's not just a pawn notice
that Knight F3 check you have Queen
takes F3 very important detail folks
when you have a situation like this the
bishop pins a piece to the queen
remember that the pin works both ways so
if the queen were let's say on B1 black
would have been able to save the Knight
with Knight F3 check and queen takes F4
this is also very pertinent in many
openings so for example in the caroon
fantasy variation um you have this type
of
situation where after Bishop C4 Knight
D7 a lot of newer players they play
Bishop takes F7 check King takes F7 and
they play Knight G5 because they learned
that this is a classic pattern but
remember here there's Queen takes G5 and
black wins again the bishop it's not the
exactly the same thing but this came to
my mind uh so remember this this
concept um anyways back we go to the
game so D5 Bishop B3 I already think is
good for good for white
D4 and we can play D4 or you can even
play Knight takes E5 I think another
great option e takes D3 you can play
Knight takes D3 and it's very it should
be very clear too that white is better
white is a better Bishop white has
better development The Rook is coming to
E1 I really think black's position here
is highly unpleasant highly unpleasant
um so I would even play Knight takes C5
in this position um against D4 so D5 is
a is a mistake I think B5 is a better
move Bishop B3 and here the main line is
Knight B to D7 so black is heading for
C5 with the Knight which is why you
should probably go A3 in order to take
the sting out of the move Knight C5
still the main move is Knight C5 Bishop
A2 and most people with black they play
A5 now we complete our development with
Bishop B3 and I contend that White's
position is still a little easier to
play because we're constantly
insinuating this move d4 which can come
at a very unpleasant moment for black
and black just a little bit cramped B4
also is a bad move because after ab4 ab4
there is a standoff between the Rooks
remember on theme uncoordinated Rooks
look for tactics Bishop F7 Rook A8 and
yeah black gets two pieces for The Rook
but you can play Bishop takes C5 DC and
Knight takes E5 and you start taking
everything all of Black's
pawns so for that reason um after Bishop
E3 black should play something like
Queen C7 this is we're still following a
game between a 2540 and a 2450 from
2018 and here white played Knight E2
getting the Knight over to G3 and you
get this very italianesque position
which in which I would definitely prefer
White Knight G3 is how the game
continued now kabanov played D5 and
white played Rook E1 maintaining the
tension and white ended up winning this
game white ended up winning this game so
this is how you know the main line goes
black can also go Knight bd7 but what
you should understand about such
positions is that it's not really about
the moves right so that you should draw
a distinction in your mind between
openings like the
nidorf which are Super theoretical you
need to memorize everything and openings
like this one where is it really going
to make such a huge difference if black
plays Knight bd7 or B fers no is it
really going to make such a huge
difference if white plays A3 or A4 no so
what you should focus on in these types
of openings is mastering the general
idea and the general piece setup so here
I would play A4 to stop B5 and then I
would complete my development with
Bishop B3 although the engine actually
really likes the move B4 expanding on
the queen side Knight E6 and even B5
just creating some tension against
Black's pawns good position for white so
that's a kind of rundown of what could
happen if uh if black would have
followed the main lines instead of C6 of
course black can also play Knight C6 and
here I would recommend the move A3 to
prevent Knight A5 much like in the GLE
game except reversed right you don't
want to Castle and allow Knight A5
because Black's going to get the bishop
pair so we you would play A3 black would
presumably Play Bishop B6 and you could
stick a knight on D5 classic move stick
a knight on D5 and if black takes it he
loses a piece black takes with a bishop
then you play e takes D5 and now the
Knight is no good square and now you can
just Castle black typically plays Knight
bd7 25 games in the day base and Bishop
back to B3 who can tell me why this move
is played why Bishop B3 why what is the
purpose of this
move to prepare C4 exactly to prepare C4
to prepare C4 and to solidify the pawns
white is better the Great Danton asks
why A3 instead of A4 A4 is very possible
I just don't love making a hole on B4
that's the literally the only reason I
don't love making a hole on B4 I'm not
suggesting that black is going to play
Knight B4 just in the long run run I
like playing it with A3 classic
traditional way in fact after A4 Bishop
B6 Knight D5 guess what black has takes
takes Knight B4 hitting the pawn so
there's a concrete reason right A3
protects the square so you can go Knight
D5 Bishop B3 Knight C5 you just play
Bishop A2 it's just a one move threat
just a one move threat and the Knight on
C5 has no future it can be kicked away
with B4 or even D4 okay so let's
consider Brian's move King h8 we decided
to prevent B5 with A4 and now Knight G8
The Logical followup the very important
takeaway is you wait you wait for your
opponent uh to remove his pieces from
the center and that's when you strike D4
F5 and here Bishop takes G8 I'm checking
with the engine was the second best move
and white is much better apparently
though white is winning after
d okay so I misevaluated this line
Knight E4 D5 is what I mentioned right
this this is a fork but we can play e
takes D6 here leading to some crazy
complications now I looked at this
position and I was really scared I was
really scared why was I scared because
there's a freaking Pawn on F3 and we
could get checkmated on G2 in the blink
of an eye but apparently white is
winning here with the move Rook e one
tempo move and the point is black has no
way to put pressure on G2 because black
is not sufficiently welldeveloped where
is the queen going to go it's probably
going to go to H4
and now look at this line 94
centralizing FG and an incredible
computer move incredible computer move
which is the only winning move hboard
awareness is very important here I'll
let you guys take a stab at it if you're
watching on YouTube pause and you know
generate three attempts
maybe now it's a logical move so a lot
of you guys are thinking Bishop G5 but
you're blundering the pawn on H3 and
you're in huge trouble there's a m
threat so you need to protect the H3
Pawn but if you do it with the Rook from
E3 then you're blocking the diagonal for
the
bishop so we do it from A3 that's the
reason I played A4 Rook A3 and if black
plays Bishop takes H3 then we play
Bishop G5 it's not the end of the line
Queen G4 and now you should notice that
the bishop on H3 is stranded so we move
the queen up to D3 hitting the bishop
twice laterally and black loses the
bishop Rook A3 for folks that's that's
quite a move that's quite a move um but
it's a it's a move that should make
sense to you you're preventing Queen
takes H3 without interfering with the
coordination of your other minor pieces
let me see if I can find an example of
this move being played this is the game
con line against Yates from 1910 Yates
was one of the top players in the world
so in this position white plays the move
F5 and he sends the bishop back to where
it came from
but after Bishop C8 con line realized
that black is threatening Rook H6 and he
probably considered E6 but rejected it
because the Rook takes there's some
tactics here The Rook on F2 is
vulnerable what do you think he played
what do you think he played I mean you
know what the move is but what's the
idea of the
move Rook A3 was found in the game Rook
H6 Rook H3 and you disarm Black's attack
and of course white has a very good
position because of these nice little
peons on F5 and
E5 okay here's another nice little nice
little moment from bobin's game here's
another nice
game different reasoning different type
of position again we see the queen on H4
Banick plays
E4 sacrificing a pawn where do you think
he goes with his rook in this position
does he go to B1 he goes to A3 why not
to go Rook H3 that's not the point why
is that not the point because the queen
itself is not an attacker right you're
not the king is not unsafe The Rook is
going to F3 in order to pile up on the
F7 pawn and uh ultimately Banick was
able to win that pawn with some tactics
and win the game through this maneuver
Rook A3 okay one more example really
really nice example okay here is one
more example it's a really hammer home
into your mind that such moves can be
found borcard Mage one of the top
players of East Germany in the 60s has
this
position and in this position black
plays the move
G4 why is black playing this move well
black is trying to rip apart White's
King side what do you think Mage played
he played Rook A3 again same idea GH you
want to meet with Rook takes H3 and this
Rook completely disarms the attack black
played Rook G8 and what subsequent
prophylactic move did malage now play
who can tell me last question and then
we'll get back to our game King H1 very
good King H1 in order so that after GH
Rook H3 there's no Queen takes H3 on
pinning the king that's it he ended up
pushing this Pawn forward and watch just
how The Rook on
A3 remains there the entire game and
it's all you need in order to secure the
defensive construction he wins all of
Black's pieces all of the other pieces
are able to attack because the Rook is
doing the defensive Duty okay I've
belabored the point enough let's go back
so Rook A3 is a move that you will now
never forget again hopefully I can be
forgiven for not evaluating this
position correctly after Rook A3 black
is screwed because if black plays a slow
move then you can infiltrate with Queen
D6 and black is just woefully
underdeveloped here here here white is
winning but I didn't evaluate this
position correctly and I figured that
after F5 a simpler idea is to play
Bishop takes G8 so that after King takes
g d Fe we're able to play Knight takes
C4 and here white is much better as well
so black has to go D5 white has to go
Knight G3 and uh the situation for black
is extremely unpleasant I think Bishop
C5 might be the decisive mistake um I
think the situation here becomes
unsalvageable I would play C5 with black
C5 and Knight C6 just to get a little
bit more breathing room for your minor
pieces I think that was maybe the only
way to stay in the game um one important
detail is that anytime there's contact
like this along the f file you should
always be aware of this overloading
tactic Bishop takes
H3 the example of this that's stuck with
me which is predicated on a slightly
different tactical idea but still it's
the same
concept in the ru Lopez Caris variation
there is a line where oh sorry wait no
it's like here let me remember it's no
no no it's here here here here here here
now you trade everything you go KN E5
and most people even GMS they go Knight
E3 they go Knight E3 and obviously they
blunder Bishop takes
H3 with the fork and if white plays F4
to dislodge the Knight who can tell me
how black saves the minor
piece I'm going to see if I can find
some instances of Bishop takes H3
tactics okay Knight C6 is correct very
good knight C6 Queen C3 Bishop D7 good
job good job Bishop D7 and black secures
the extra
Pawn literally I did a search and within
two seconds I was able to find like a
thousand examples of strong players
missing this tactic uh this is from 1879
alipin the person was black and in this
position alipin okay white PL Queen D2
alapin played F4 white played Knight
takes D5 F E3 Knight E3 bang Bishop
takes H3 chopping away at the pawn and
white White's King side kind of
collapses so this is one simple
example here is a slightly more involved
example and I hope people enjoy these
detours just to give you more of a sense
of how this tactic operates in real life
so it's black to play in this position
let's flip the board what you should
notice looking at the queen side is that
the bishop is hanging but then so is the
Knight what tactic did Black come up
with very ingenious in order to
circumvent this and give himself a
chance how do I find this
magic Bishop takes H3 G takes H3 now he
threw in a check and the point of course
is that now The Rook on F guards the
Knight and black actually ended up
winning this game because that very same
Knight it eventually traveled to D4
which which is a beautiful Outpost in
Black one um so watch out for Bishop
takes H3 as well keep that in mind
especially when the f file is open okay
so Bishop C5 Bishop E3 which I think was
a very important move because it traded
off Black's only developed piece and it
set the preconditions for the decisive
invasion in the center it opens up the f
file It prepares E4 I think I explained
this during the game is anybody confused
by Bishop E3 or is this making sense to
people like why are we agreeing to ruin
our structure what are we getting in
return for it while we're getting the f
file we're getting the possibility of
playing E4 I mean we're getting pass
Pawn on E5 and we're eliminating Black's
only piece that's developed leaving
black completely undeveloped Knight D7
and immediately we play E4 ripping open
the center Queen B6 King H1 D takes E4
Knight takes
E4 probably
something like Knight C5 would have been
more resilient but black is already
losing and after Queen takes B2 it took
me a little while but I was able to find
the force to win also winning was Queen
D6 this was also crushing this is the
move that you could play in a bullet
game because this requires no
calculation black is simply paralyzed if
black tries to move the Knight away then
you can play E6 and I'll leave this to
you to figure out why this is so winning
okay Knight F6 and here I looked for a
win for a while and I was able to find
it E7 Rook E8 and Knight G5 and to just
demonstrate the the key line over the
board um Knight takes E4 Rook f8 check
trade and then Queen d8 is back rank
mate with F7 guarded so that was a very
important line another important line
was what happens if the queen drops back
to E5 and here you need to resist the
temptation as some of you might have to
play Queen d8 which is a very
ineffective move because black moves the
bishop away and now the Rooks are
defending each other and the queen is
attacked does anybody can anybody tell
me what the best move is here this is a
much more challenging question this is a
much more challenging question it's not
Knight takes F6 immediately nope it's
not Knight F6 I I'll give you some time
to think about it let me refill my
water okay a lot of you are forgetting
that after the the pawn captures on F6
black now has Rook takes E7 and The Rook
guards H7 so anytime a pawn moves away
from its initial Square you need to
consider okay well what are the new How
does the structure change and one way
the structure changes is that Rook takes
C7 now guards H7 the correct move is
Queen F3 which is a very difficult move
to play because it it it uh involves
giving away the E7 Pawn why are you
giving it away in order to bring all of
the pieces to the party Rook ae1 wins
the game black is getting fried in the
center completely
fried okay so this is a classic example
of transforming the advantage from one
type of advantage to another that's it
Knight E4 Queen f8 if black plays H6 you
can just play takes takes and Rook takes
again it's very easy to understand why
this position is winning black has no
moves everything
collapses everything collapses there is
a nice line Bishop E6 you play Knight
takes C6
Rook takes C6 takes takes Queen B3 and
you win the game because you hit the
rook and hit the queen um not Queen G4
because of Rook takes E1 and The Rook is
pinned so you actually also have to pin
The Rook accuracy until the end so
that's what I was looking for when I
played Knight fg5 that's what I was
calculating now in the game Brian played
Knight Bishop G4 we played Queen D3 and
the game ended immediately of course
Rook E7 was more resilient and I was
just planning to take the bishop and and
just convert the extra piece according
to the engine the fastest way to win is
actually to do this and then just to
play Rook a to E1 apparently this is
just crushing on the spot because black
is Black's king is too white open
everything is coming in so I probably
would have gone for this in a classical
game but given the time pressure I
wanted to secure the loot I wanted to
make sure that we have that extra piece
you know in the bank but yeah
technically Knight F6 was the best move
but the game is already over here um any
questions now I'm not saying this is the
only win Rog B1 is winning maybe
immediately Knight G5 is winning but I
think this was the most straightforward
uh that was a great game I thought it
was a really interesting game only 23
moves but a lot happened in those 23
moves a lot of tactics in the middle
game yeah I'm pretty pumped at
[Music]
that